good morning everybody what a night it
has been labor has taken control of two
key conservative london strongholds as
election results come in from right
across the country the party will
celebrate the wins in one smith uh
taking the council for the first time in
more than 40 years and westminster while
some in boris johnson's own party have
blamed the prime minister for the loss
the conservatives have sustained the
national picture is mixed however you
can see tomorrow's with us liberal dems
and the greens taking seats off both the
tories and labour but all eyes good
morning to you tomorrow on westminster
council cheapest council tax in the
country
never been labor in its history morning
care yes absolutely and that was also at
the top of labour's expectations
although we expected labour to do well
in london they've had a terrific night
taking one's worth which was thought to
be the closest we expect they're also
going to be taking barnet off the
conservatives pretty imminently when
that declares and westminster where the
tories had double the number of
councillors that labour did it was seen
as very difficult for labour to actually
take that one um but we've had quite a
stunning result there for labour and a
difficult message for the conservatives
having campaigned on the doorstep saying
if you're struggling with the cost of
living look the council which could
which is the one thing it controls is
council tax will give you low council
tax and good services and that message
did not cut through on the doorstep with
us hearing that partygate and national
issues were really affecting voter
turnout in those key areas rest of the
country a more mixed picture though okay
you're going to crunch all the numbers
for me i know throughout the course of
the show thanks very much indeed
tomorrow so where is the second lowest
council tax in the country
once worth john craig is there john good
morning
morning kay this has been a dramatic
night here we at the big start of the
evening we were told it was neck and
neck too close to call but gradually it
became clear that the tories were
suffering defeats losing some awards to
labor one grande shook his head and said
it's gone and the labor celebrations got
more and more raucous as the night went
on led by the mayor of london sadiq khan
they are jubilant here cockerhoop in the
words of the labour mayor sadiq khanna
former mp here in this uh in this
borough this con
the constituency of tooting as for the
tories well for lorne subdued uh broken
and bruised the outgoing tory leader
admitted that partygate had come up on
the doorstep the cost of living he even
said that neil parish the tory mp
looking at pawn on his phone in the
house of commons have been a factor here
okay that's uh how it's looking in
wandsworth this morning john thanks so
much indeed for the analysis thank you
join now by the co-chair of the
conservative party and that's oliver
dowden great to see thanks for joining
us on the program this morning i'm sure
you've not had much sleep uh overnight
crunching all these numbers but given
that uh wandsworth's just hearing second
lowest council tax in the country
westminster lowest council tax in the
country they've both gone labour it's
not about the cost of living is it so
what's it about
well of course we've had some difficult
results and you've seen that in those
places in london i would say though
actually if you look across the country
we've made gains in places like hartley
poor we've made them in thorac we've
made them in in uneaten and actually
given that we're mid-term i think it
really doesn't show that labour have the
momentum to form the next government but
inevitably midterm we are going to have
challenges like this what's it down to
that you've lost these two
prime council seats in in the capital
including the palace of westminster is
in western council
well i i think it's worth looking at the
two of them so first of all in relation
to wandsworth
we only won that by about 200 votes last
time around it was an unexpected hold
there is a general momentum across
london which you you've seen here and
you you saw actually in the past 20
years worth of elections in wandsworth
of us doing less well but of course as
as john said in his intro to this piece
there have been challenging headlines
for the past few months but i do think
that set against all of that those sort
of challenges that you would expect
after 12 years in office these are a
challenging result but we have have made
progress in lots of places so it has to
be viewed in that context okay this is
what the outgoing leader of wandsworth
council said
yes it did come up i'm not denying that
that didn't come i mean the the mr
parish's watching of television
of porn on his phone came up several
times i think there were a number of
people picking up different things that
they were concerned about and that came
up on the doorstep
potty gate tractor gate
yes well of course there have been lots
of difficult headlines for the past few
months and i suppose okay that's the the
point that i'm making that if you set
that these results against those
difficult headlines and if you set them
against the fact that we've been in
power for the past 12 years we're really
not seeing the kind of results so you
saw two years before 97 that blair
victory that was 1800 seats worth of
gains for the labour party
william hague uh i think gained about
1300 in 2000 and then went on to lose
the 2001 election so i of course accept
that these are challenging times and
there have been some difficult results
however i do not accept that labour have
the momentum to form the next government
of course we now in response to that as
a government need to make sure that we
really focus not on those kind of
headlines in the way that the leader was
describing but on what matters to people
whether that is tackling the cost of
living but that's clearing those nhs
backlogs or taking advantage of the
opportunities given us by leaving the
european union or perhaps getting rid of
the leader i mean you've got three mps i
think in the cumbria carlisle
area and this is what the leader of uh
carlyle council has had to say
i've never been a fan of boris johnson
anyway
i've never made any great secrets of
that fact
and i think
i think you should consider his position
now i'm i fully expect that there will
be
more letters to the chairman of the
uh 22 committee
yep labour won the new uh council of
cumberland which will take in color
but time to the boss down to the boss
again well i think and i i have have
great uh respect for him but he he
himself admitted that he was never the
biggest fan of the the prime minister
actually i think that what you see in
the prime minister is somebody who gets
things done a change maker and whether
that's in relation to the vaccine
program fastest vaccine roll out uh
three times over or what he's been doing
in ukraine we need that kind of bold uh
leadership and i think precisely at a
time when we're facing these big
challenges whether it's cost of living
whether it's ukraine whether it's the
economic situation around the world that
you heard the basketball that you heard
in the past uh the past 24 hours i think
we need somebody that can really grip
things and deliver that change and i
think that's what we've got in boris
johnson well the leader of uh the
conservatives in scotland of course uh
didn't agree this is what he said uh
previously i think what we've seen over
the last few days is more and more mps
uh publicly saying they take a similar
position to me and there's a feeling
that we're getting closer and closer to
the 54 number of letters required to go
into the 1922 committee he said that
back in january he was pressurized he
subsequently retracted that but that's
one of your own saying he's not the
right man for the job well i've i've
actually obviously as you might imagine
i was campaigning up in in scotland and
i i met with douglas while i was up
there and as you say he has that's not
his view now and i think he accepts as
indeed most people
that i spoke to
touring the length and breadth of the
country
they recognize what boris johnson has
done during this ukraine crisis the kind
of leadership he's shown they recognize
actually the leadership that he showed
during the the covid crisis with driving
that vaccine role and of course people
remember that he delivered brexit as he
promised and that's the kind of
focus and energy that that we need and i
think that's what he brings i'm glad you
brought brexit up because where are we
going to be in northern ireland they
start
counting in about 45 minutes time or
something like that
if shin fein takes power we could find
ourselves in a position
where boris johnson is the prime
minister who oversees the breakup of the
union
well first of all let's let's wait and
see what the results are from northern
ireland that's what all the projects and
well
i hope you appreciate that we will know
that in in 24 hours you you rightly
highlight the provisions of the the
peace agreements there which do provide
that if this is a sustained uh majority
nationalist
opinion in in favor of uh united island
that that would have to be put forward
in a a referendum that's that's kind of
beyond the power of of the united
kingdom government in that sense we'd
have to allow that to happen where at
the case but let's wait and see what
happened yeah let's let's just remind
our viewers what it actually
shares the uh northern ireland agreement
a crucial component to was the provision
for a a border poll committing both
governments in an internationally
binding agreement to legislate for
reunification if a simple majority of
northern ireland's electorate voted in
favour that could be
a reality if shin fein wins that must
make boris johnson's blood run cold this
morning
well boris johnson is as i am and the
entire cabinet we're passionate
unionists and we believe in the value of
northern ireland as part of our united
kingdom of course
we would honour the provisions of the
good friday agreement if that was
required but i'm confident that we will
be able to make the case for northern
ireland remaining in the united kingdom
should that uh that arise but i don't
think we're at that stage left so that's
not going to be within 12 hours well
let's let's wait george used to sat just
where you are earlier on this week and
said that the british government would
step in to prevent that happening that's
not going to happen is it if endangering
fein wins and we do press towards a
border referendum the british government
would allow that to happen wouldn't they
well the british government will respect
its
treaty obligations including in the the
good friday agreement but i don't think
we're we're anywhere near that so
joshua's just misspoke when he said that
earlier in the week well i'm afraid i
didn't hear exactly what george used to
said but i'm very clear that we will
respect our international obligations
but as i say i don't think we are we are
close to invoking the provisions of that
yeah as i said i'll let me put that to
you again
this prime minister could be the prime
minister that oversees the splitting up
of the union if that were to happen with
northern ireland all eyes would be
towards scotland
well okay i think you're you're jumping
many steps ahead here so first of all we
don't know the results in in northern
ireland and in any event uh we have the
provisions of that
treaty i'm absolutely confident that the
people of northern ireland
as has been shown on many occasions
before would choose to remain within the
united kingdom so i don't actually think
that that eventuality will arise well
we'll see as you said um whatever
happens in the next 12 hours even if
sinn fein does win in northern ireland
we see what happens in wales
and also up in scotland where you're not
likely to do very well whatever happens
you still feel that boris johnson is the
right man to lead your party
well i think looking at the the picture
of the results so far they demonstrate
that whilst there have been difficult
results they are consistent with what
you'd expect with us from mid-term
labour are certainly not on the path to
power and i believe that boris johnson
does have the leadership skills in
particular the energy and the dynamism
that we need during this difficult
period of time so no i don't think we
should uh removed boris johnson as our
prime minister i think we should stick
with him i think he's got the skills we
need to lead us into the next okay what
happens uh if it transpires in the
coming weeks which it's likely to that
he's broken the law on more than uh one
occasion uh and as a result has misled
parliament would he still be the right
man for the job
well may i take each one of those in in
turnkey first of all
you'll expect me to say but i'll have to
say it which is i'm not going to indulge
in hypotheticals it it's right as a
cabinet minister i allow the police to
do their job i don't actually believe
that he misled parliament i think he
gave a very clear explanation of that
and what what he said at the time in
parliament he genuinely believed to be
the case and i think taking into account
all of these things and by the way i've
i've been clear on this show and many
others i don't for a moment resile from
my anger and frustration about what
happened in downing street and i think
the prime minister has shown a rightly
shown remorse over that and he feels a
frustration about it as well i have
accepted what he said in respect to that
because i believe that we need to
balance that against his considerable
achievements which i've already outlined
to you and the need for the energy and
dynamism to to lead this country forward
and i believe that he has that do you
want my viewers who are watching this
morning to honestly believe that this
man presided over
the biggest rule breaking in the whole
of the country in one street and he
didn't know what was happening under his
own roof because obviously the
electorate doesn't think that
well
first of all i think the prime minister
has given an explanation of that and
there's not a great deal that i i can
add to i thought it was a very clear
explanation i think many of your viewers
and i certainly found this when i was
speaking people do
recognize and acknowledge the
considerable achievements of the united
kingdom government led by boris johnson
in getting the vaccine program that's
not the case i think you you'll also see
that uh if if you look for example the
decision that we took to keep the
economy open i remember in the run-up to
christmas starmer drakeford sturgeon
many elements of the media i should say
actually not sky news we're demanding
that we shut the economy back down the
prime minister made the very difficult
call to keep the economy open which
means we have
unemployment falling
we have strong growth
and i think people recognize those
things now okay you talk about the the
results and i have um
accepted that there are difficult
results in london but i do think that
those are more consistent with what you
would expect from a government
in mid-term in a battleground that is
dominated by urban areas that tend to
favor the the the labour party and those
results uh as disappointed as i
genuinely am that we've lost excellent
public servants in both of those
councils and elsewhere
i i think that those are consistent with
trends that you have seen previously and
not mr party children we're almost at a
change of government you see elsewhere
mr pottery we're almost out of time i've
illustrated to you in some detail why
when you have lost seats that you you
would you would have thought that you
wouldn't lose boros in london
westminster council cheapest council tax
in the whole of the country they said
it's because of boris johnson i've
illustrated to you that boris johnson
could be the prime minister that
oversees the breakup of the union i've
illustrated to you that he could
undoubtedly find himself in a position
where he's going to get more fines from
the metropolitan police they gave him
the courtesy of waiting until after the
election in order before they issued
more fines and you're still sitting
there and telling our viewers this
morning this man can do no wrong
i'm not saying that this man can do do
no wrong and
i've accepted the considerable mistakes
that were made in downing street but
i've also accepted the explanation that
he's given i've highlighted uh the
considerable achievements he's had
whether that's with the vaccine program
where that's leading the world in our
the democratic world's response to the
ukraine crisis or whether that's in
respect of getting brexit done and i
think when those things are considered
in the balance the right thing is that
as people are worried about these
challenges
caused by this global the
global challenges of both recovering
from covid and the pressure on inflation
ukraine crisis both national security
and the economy we need strong and clear
leadership and i think the boris johnson
delivers that okay it's good to talk to
you i must let you go a busy round of
media chats this morning for you thank
you for joining us on the program mr
chairman thank you
well the elections results were too late
for this morning's papers as you can
imagine but let's take a look at what is
on their front page is the metro leads
with news from the bank of england that
inflation is likely to exceed 10 later
this year as the cost of living crisis
bites the telegraph points out that we
could see the highest inflation for 40
years as you might expect that's also
the big story for the ft this morning
and also the guardian
the eye says that the average hit to
families will be around 1200 pounds but
there's no help in sight until the next
budget
all of which says the mail amounts to a
record squeeze on families
while the time says there's growing
pressure from the cabinet for the
chancellor to cut taxes to stave off
recession
but the express
says recession is already on its way
okay some breaking news and that's
actually just uh happened as the
chairman walked out of the studio which
is a shame because i would have put it
to him uh labor has uh beaten the
conservatives in the london borough of
barnet as well another blow for the
conservatives in the capital city of
england
lots of reaction to the elections still
to come on the program for you including
throughout the programme the deputy
first minister of scotland john swinney
is joining me later in the hour
also be hearing from the welsh
government's minister economy minister i
should say that's horn getting
and the leader of the lib dems sir ed
davies also on the program as early
results suggest the party could be
making gains
[Music]
time now for a deep dive into some of
the results as they currently stand
nobody better to do that for us this
morning than helen and she's at sky news
center hi helen and good morning
good morning kay it's been a fantastic
night so far and fascinating set of
results still to come in as you can see
our big grid here that we are gradually
filling in as we get the results is
getting a little bit less gray and a
little bit more colored in and all eyes
k this morning have been on london
those three big big scalps that labour
have taken
barnet wandsworth and westminster so the
barnett result we have literally just
have him let's bring you some of the
detail here and look what a take it is
labour taking barnet from the
conservatives by 12 whole seats they've
picked up from the conservatives they're
worth saying last time this seat uh was
fought in 2018 the conservative actually
made gains uh against labor it was seen
largely at the time a bit of a backlash
against jeremy corbyn amidst the
allegations of anti-semitism he was
facing at the time there's a big jewish
community in barnet kistama will see
this as evidence that he's really
starting to rebuild some of that trust
with the jewish community a huge huge
gain
for labor continuing this brilliant
story for labor in london their
brilliant performance westminster it has
never been held
by labour and look 13 seats that labour
took
off the conservatives there and just
have a look at this wandsworth is the
other
council that we've been talking about
all night the numbers there really
really impressive but this is actually
what i want to show you the vote share
in ones worth and just look at that gap
that's existed between the conservatives
and the labour vote share in wandsworth
going all the way back to the mid-90s
really and just look at that that is
exactly what labour will be jubilant
about today that crossing over after all
of that time of the vote share in places
like wandsworth but look it's important
to say that outside london labour are
also going to need to make important big
gains if they stand any chance of
winning the next general election and of
course that's what ultimately they want
so how have they done outside london
well it is a slightly more mixed picture
have a look at this hartley pool this is
the type of place that labor need to be
making big gains uh if they want to take
the next general election big collapse
in support in places like this uh around
that brexit election in 2019 and look no
change for the labour party here worth
saying that really represents a return
to their strength that they had in 2018
when this was last fought but not major
gains not major inroads uh so a mix a
slightly more nuanced picture i think
okay outside of london but certainly in
london labour will be very very pleased
indeed with how things are going okay
thanks helen and thank you let's take
you to northern ireland now where
tensions are high in the stormont
election as unionists and republicans
vie for the top spot which entitles them
to nominate the next first minister
counting due to begin at the top of the
hour joe has been dispatched for us hi
joe um i don't know if you heard what
the chairman of the conservative party
um had to say he was saying not getting
involved in those discussions until
later on in the day but it could be a
real challenge for the government
couldn't it
it certainly could okay we expect
brandon lewis northern ireland secretary
to be here maybe on monday or tuesday
next week we could see negotiations
meanwhile his junior minister connor
burns is in the united states because i
think uh the conservatives realize that
politicians there also do have a
significant
stake and have strong views on this
including of course the president
president biden counting here as you say
should begin in the next hour or so but
do not expect results very quickly it
could be the end of tomorrow before we
have the final numbers the final tallies
because this is a proportional system
people don't just put an x by a counter
or party they want they put numbers and
therefore second and third preferences
can be decisive but for the last 24
years the biggest party in the assembly
installment has always been a unionist
party for the last 19 years that's been
the democratic unionist the dup
now opinion polls suggest shin fein a
nationalist party a party that believes
in united island a party that does not
believe in the uh northern ireland's
place in the union could be that largest
party and therefore could have the first
minister's job to this poses a lot of
questions firstly whether if the dep
comes second they'll want to take part
in the government secondly what the uk
government do with the northern ireland
protocol they've certainly indicated
that unhappy with it and want to
renegotiate with the eu and thirdly what
does this mean for the union because by
the end of tomorrow we could have a
situation where the northern ireland
assembly
and the scottish parliament both have
the biggest parties uh being parties in
the snp and chimfane that do not believe
in those countries place in the uk
okay but now thanks thanks joe
pressure attempt to evacuate civilians
from i should say that we'll come back
obviously um to our discussion about
those council elections and indeed the
northern ireland assembly when that
starts to count in about half an hour's
time
let me tell you what's happening in
ukraine though a fresh attempt to
evacuate civilians from the ukrainian
port city of mario paul is planned for
this morning the un secretary general
has said in a joint operation with the
international red cross two safe passage
convoys successfully evacuated nearly
500 people from the avistal plant mario
paul and the surrounding areas
however russia has been accused of
flooding ceasefire agreements and
continuing to attack the steelworks
where soldiers and civilians continue to
shelter
new pictures released by the ukrainian
azov battalion who remain inside the
plant show explosions sky news has not
been able to verify when the footage was
taken the battalion's deputy commander
has russia says russia is continuing its
attempts to force their way inside
the third day in a row the enemy has
broken through on the territory of the
azov style plant where heavy bloody
fighting continues
the defenders of the city have been
fighting on their own for 71 days with
the overwhelming forces of the enemy
and damn it they show such endurance and
heroism that the whole of ukraine must
know what it means to be faithful to the
homeless
well as the russian siege of mario paul
continues some of the ukrainians still
inside the steel works have been
attempting to keep spirits
[Music]
footage upon to show ukrainian soldiers
singing below the steelworks sky news
has for now been unable to independently
verify the date and location of the
video
well boris johnson has said the uk will
continue to assist ukraine for as long
as is needed speaking at a fundraising
event the prime minister said it was
vital to support the humanitarian effort
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
thanked the uk for their help
bravery is rightly believed the first of
human qualities
as it guarantees all others
looking at some of the other headlines
for you now and let me tell you about
the actress amber heard she told a court
in virginia about the physical and
sexual abuse she claims took place at
the hands of her ex-husband johnny depp
mr depp is suing his ex-wife for
defamation over an article where she
accused him of domestic violence the
actor was not specifically mentioned in
the article and has denied ever hitting
as heard just a warning this clip
concludes a distressing description of
violence
he just hit me over and over and over
again and i got really still
and it
felt in my body like quiet
and
i thought this is how i die
he's gonna kill me now and i'm not
he's gonna kill me and he
won't even have
realized it
roman abramovich has insisted his
position over the sale of chelsea is
unchanged and has described claims he
has asked for a one and a half billion
pound loan to be paid back as entirely
false reports had suggested the russian
billionaire could insist on the money
being paid back which could threaten the
sale of the premier league club
joe biden's made history after
announcing his new white house press
secretary karen jean-pierre will become
both the first black woman and the first
openly gay person to take up the
position incumbent jenn sackey is due to
leave the post in a week's time
this is a historic moment and it's not
lost on me
i understand how important it is for so
many
people out there
so many different communities that i
stand on their shoulders and i have been
throughout my career and so it is an
honor and a privilege to be behind this
podium
well despite those losses in london the
co-chair of the conservative party has
defended the election results coming in
although he did concede that difficult
headlines
whatever that means had had an impact
oliver dowden told me that set against
the circumstance labour is not making
large gains on the party
there have been lots of difficult
headlines for the past few months and i
suppose okay that's the the point that
i'm making that if you set that
these results against those difficult
headlines and if you set them against
the fact that we've been in power for
the past 12 years we're really not
seeing the kind of results say you saw
two years before 97 that blair victory
that was 1800 seats worth of gains for
the labour party william hague i think
gained about 1300 in 2000 and then went
on to lose the 2001 election so i of
course accept that these are challenging
times and there have been some difficult
results however i do not accept that
labour have the momentum to form the
next government
tomorrow's here as you can see tomorrow
um breaking news since oliver darden has
left uh the conservatives have lost
another seat yes they've lost barnet
council which we looked looked like it
might fall to labor and it's now
confirmed that labour have gained 12
seats from the conservatives so they're
on 41 conservatives on 22. now this
hasn't always been conservative but it's
been pretty much mostly conservative
since the 1960s significant because it
looked like labor were on course to take
it last time in 2018 but of course it
has a big jewish population the
anti-semitism scandal and the labour
party had a big impact labour
councillors spoke very emotionally at
the time about how they were being told
they were a racist party on the
doorsteps looks like that has turned
around now where labour have won back
support and i wouldn't be at all
surprised if we saw kierstarma there
today because he has made it his mission
he says to stamp out anti-semitism to
reverse the impressions people had of
jeremy corbyn when he was leading the
party and it looks like they've done
that
wider picture though wider picture
though is labour having a terrific night
in london mustn't be underestimated what
a win westminster is that was really at
the top of labour's ambitions in london
elsewhere look labour have had good
results elsewhere they've taken
southampton off the tories they have
taken a council in cumbria cumberland
council so that is perhaps a sign of a
bit of red wall revival there but in
former industrial towns outside london
we are still seeing the conservatives
holding on now that may not be a great
result for them but you're looking at
areas like hartlepool where the
conservative had a stunning victory and
by-election last year still doing pretty
well so the conservatives are keen to
say look this is not a labour party on
the brink of going into government of
taking power in a general election but i
still think labour are feeling very
encouraged by those results a lot of the
seats this time in england are being
fought in london so we have to make
clear that the picture we're getting
from across the country there isn't
voting everywhere there's only voting in
certain areas but what we're seeing so
far is big wins for labour in london and
a bit of a standstill in some other
areas of the country where they will
need to win back support to win a future
general election and that will be a bit
of an alarm bell for kierstarma and will
be some relief for the conservatives
yeah voting also of course in scotland
uh yesterday and uh let's uh head up to
scotland now should we and speak to one
of the representatives
of the snp should we the deputy
first minister is joining us now and
that's john swinney hello to mr swinney
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning labor not doing quite as
well as they might have anticipated uh
doing very well in london how do you
think they uh will be as a worthy
contenders against the snp in scotland
obviously we've not seen any ballot
boxes opened yet in scotland but my
expectation would be that
the snp will come out of this election
as the leading party in scotland as
interesting to hear
oliver dowden saying that um the
conservatives were having a tough night
because they've been in par in power for
12 years while the snp has been in power
for 15 and
we're still winning elections i think
the labour party will do better in this
election than they did in 2017
but obviously we'll have to wait till we
see the results in the course of today
as to what that looks like because
always as you as you've just been
discussing it's a very variable picture
in england
for the labour party sounds as though
you're preparing your members and
supporters of the smp for not doing
quite as well as you have done
previously
not all i think the snp is going to win
this election i think we've
we've demonstrated
consistently through this campaign that
we've got the ideas to take scotland
forward on tackling the cost of living
of ensuring that we have the measures in
place to support families who are facing
a really hard time that's gonna that's
gonna significantly damage the
conservatives as it's been shown
in other parts of the uk because of the
insensitivity and the lack of action on
the cost of living crisis
and also to demonstrate that we've got
the ideas for taking scotland forward
on
the whole question of the future of
scotland so i'm very confident about our
performance in the local authority
elections they're obviously different
elections to a scottish parliament
contest there's
large parts of the country are contested
by independent candidates that don't
have a party affiliation so that
obviously affects the dynamics of the
campaign but i'm very confident the smp
will be the leading party at the
conclusion of this election yeah the
reason i ask you that mr swinney is
because i know that the snp promise free
laptops um tablets to every child bikes
to the poorest children to reinvest in
play parks and and what i'm being told
is that you didn't deliver on those
promises
to the extent that people would have
expected and that could then put
yourself in a position where you don't
have as many seats as you were expecting
well these these promises that you that
you refer to kay are are five-year
parliamentary promises so on on each of
those commitments we are making progress
we only made those commitments 12 months
ago and we are continuing on the issue
of laptops for example over 75 000
laptops have been issued to a children
young people in scotland to support
their education and we're rolling out
all of these programs over the course of
parliament of course people can see what
the snp government delivers you know we
promised that
we would introduce an expansion of early
learning and child care so that all we
essentially doubled the provision of air
learning chelsea
and we've delivered that in full and
there are commitments such as the
application of free prescriptions which
has been put in place by an snp
government and maintained so i think
what people can see in scotland is a
bold snp government that continues to
deliver and will deliver that program
over the course of the five the
five-year parliamentary term if you make
gains would you consider that to be a
mandate for another referendum
well we've got the mandate for a
referendum on independence we got that
last year in the scottish parliament
elections
we
we were elected on the last year of the
vote of any party in the history of
devolution in scotland and there's a
parliamentary majority for the holding
of a referendum on the question of
independence so we've got that mandate
i'm absolutely certain that by getting
into a leading position in this local
authority election the political
momentum continues to be with us and
what we want to make sure is that the
mandate that we achieved last may is
respected and put into place so that we
can have a referendum on scotland's
constitutional future yeah my
understanding is though that you need
permission from westminster in order to
be able to hold a referendum in scotland
very different to what the situation
is potentially in northern ireland you
must be looking across the irish sea
with some envy
there's obviously a very dynamic
situation emerging in northern ireland
and we'll obviously watch that with
interest we work with the
other administrations in the united
kingdom on various questions of um
policy and
operations we've worked very closely
with the devolved administrations in
wales and northern ireland to press the
uk government to do more for example on
the cost of living and obviously there's
an opportunity for us to continue that
cooperation as we work to make sure that
the priorities and the concerns of
people in scotland are properly and
fully taken into account by a
conservative government that's frankly
ignoring what people are experiencing in
the real world
what would a sinn fein victory
in northern ireland assembly mean for
the people of scotland do you think
i think what it would mean is that we
would have
political leadership in northern ireland
which was prepared to challenge the
united kingdom government on many
aspects of its policy approach i think
to be fair to
the dup they've been prepared to do that
on certain questions but on some of the
very important questions uh less so
so there's an opportunity for us to work
together to pressurise the uk government
to ensure
that they address the very real
difficulties that people are facing in
their lives today particularly around
the cost of living and to have an
intervention that
actually addresses the depth of the
crisis that people are facing
quick thought before i let you go the
way it's shaking down at this stage it
looks as though um labour would if it's
converted into a general election result
tomorrow labour would not have an
overall majority nowhere near could uh
labor if they did find themselves in
that position uh count on the support of
the snp
obviously we've made it clear that we're
prepared to engage in political dialogue
with other political parties we draw a
line at the conservatives we we think
the conservatives take a hostile agenda
which we're not prepared to go along
with so we're happy to engage in in
dialogue with political parties but it
has to be meaningful dialogue that
delivers progress on the agenda which
we're interested in and an agenda that
will deliver on the future of the people
of scotland
voting st i think counting starts soon
doesn't it
um it's not certainly my local authority
it starts at nine o'clock so i'll be
heading there very shortly very good
it's great to talk to you thanks for
sparing the time
thank you thank you
let's take me to wales now should we the
welsh economy minister vaughan getting
is joining us from cardiff hello to you
uh miss miss kevin thank you for uh
joining us on the program this morning
um
i wonder if you could give me an
overview of the results that we've seen
so far because of i think i'm right in
saying that accounting hasn't started in
wales yet either
that's correct so welsh councils will be
counting uh from this morning onwards
and all 22 of our local authorities have
had elections here in wales so
rob's taking an interest in results
around the rest of the uk but my obvious
focus as a welsh labor minister is how
we're going to do in wales
and i'm optimistic we'll see some gains
in seats and the number of councils that
we run but we'll uh we'll find all that
out for real in the next few hours okay
we will but of course um you know you
can't run a labour government without uh
seats uh being one in scotland and in
england as well um and
it's it's been a bit disappointing
really hasn't it outside of the capital
of england um the other areas uh of the
country has been a bit disappointing for
the labour party
uh it's always the fact that when you
haven't had quite all of the results
there are people saying it's really
disappointing or it's dreadful depending
which way you look at it and actually
we're seeing gains being made across the
uk what will be important for us is to
see where we land when all the results
are counted and then to see where the
momentum is within the country and when
i've been knocking doors here in wales
there's been a real mix of issues on the
doorstep some of them really are ultra
local issues and people have said blood
needs to be on the doorstep they will
make a local choice but on
national uk or welsh issues they would
vote in a different way so you do see
some of that boat splitting and a much
lower turnout in these elections as well
but i think we'll find ourselves in a
much stronger position across the uk at
the end of these results and as i say
i'm looking forward with real interest
to the results we have here in wales
we
were anticipating uh as we were
preparing for um the local elections
that cost of living would be a really
big issue but looking at the results in
london you know where the cheapest and
the next cheapest council taxes are in
the whole of the country
they've both uh voted labor so
potentially it's not all uh about the
cost of living it's it's about other
issues as well what did you find
as i say it was a mix and it goes back
to the first point you were making about
can you make progress well
if you want a uk labor government then
the results in westminster mata don't
know so four tory marginal seats and we
do find that there were people looking
at their local council
other people were more interested in the
national picture when i was on the
doorstep local issues came up the cost
of living did come up it was also a
factor that when i was knocking doors
unsurprisingly people talked about the
pandemic response and the difference
between wales and england but the prime
minister came up and i was genuinely
surprised by the number of parents that
were unhappy and parents of all voting
persuasions who were saying if the prime
minister can do that what do i tell my
children about right then wrong and that
was a very strong feature indoors and i
knocked doors in over half the lock
authorities in wales so
local
cost of living the prime minister and
the pandemic were the big issues that i
found on the doorstep
and just remind our viewers i know but
you tell them it's better coming from
you when uh you start counting
uh we're going to verify the votes from
half a state nine o'clock this morning
and you should start to have results
coming through in the hours afterwards
you'll get a full set of results from
wales later on this afternoon okay
sensational thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
take care
sarah davey's with me now hi hi that's a
big smile on your face yeah well you
know you said on tuesday would i come
back on friday morning and i'm certainly
back here i also said the voters could
use their ballots to send a message to
boris johnson on the cost of living and
have they done that have they though is
it like cost of living because i don't
know if you just listened to the point
that i was making there that
the cheapest council taxes in the
country are both in london here and yet
that wasn't what was on people's minds
when they were voting it was about the
leader well i i think it was about
heating bills
and food bills and prices at the the
pump and the fact that conservatists
refuse to take the the sort of decisions
that are needed you know the democrats
have argued for a
a tax cut uh worth 600 pounds for the
average family paid for by windfall tax
on the oil and gas companies and that's
a fair approach the conservatives
aren't doing that um cost living was
definitely there
and then we of course we saw the nhs as
a big issue as well
and that's why liberal democrats i think
have made these historic gains we've
gone into tory heartland we we're
winning in wimbledon which is a seat we
hope to take the next election west
oxfordshire uh places in greater
manchester like stockport cheadle and
hazel grove constituencies so um uh yeah
i have a smile on my face today
you would say you're re-emerging as a
party as an electoral force i would say
people are using this as a protest vote
against the government no because
there's a real trend now uh last year we
took cheshire and true blue
buckinghamshire a palm tree by election
then we took north shropshire uh see the
tourist health for 200 years in a rural
community uh and uh we've had us
several years now of really good local
election results so this is isn't just
one-off this is a real trend but how do
you manage how do you get to convert
that into a general election
fair question but i could point to a
number of councils where we've made real
progress where um if we repeat that
progress at a general election we'll win
a lot of conservative seats so i
mentioned uh wimbledon i mentioned
cheadle hazel grove these are liberal
democrat uh target seats where we think
we can remove the conservative mp and
only the liberal democrats in those
sorts of areas and if you remember after
the cheshire ambition by election i i
had that
a little photo where i knocked down the
blue wall as a symbol of the fact that
the liberal democrats are taking the
conservatives on in their heartlands and
we've got some more results to come in
some really important results
into rural counties like
somerset and cumbria let's see what
happens there but if some of the results
that the liberal democrats are achieving
against the conservatives are repeated
you know we could get even more gains
than we made so far this is what
happened in kingston upon whole you
actually took uh seats there from labor
yeah that's right didn't you now i would
say um
how are you going to convert that again
i'll put it to you how are you going to
convert it when it becomes a general
election because you talked about the
by-elections again those are protest
votes they tend to be but when it comes
to the general election you don't seem
to be able to knock down those blue
walls with your swinging bat well let's
just wait and see kay
i mean increasingly hearing from people
hearing from voters they are very
unhappy not just with boris johnson but
with the whole conservative party
their failure to listen to voters who
are really
really suffering millions of pensioners
and families across the country
wanting want leadership on the cost of
living they're not getting that from the
conservatives they're really worried
about the health of their family about
cancer waiting times for example
no action from the conservatives and
with the conservative government failing
people on the economy and on health it's
no wonder that they're turning against
it and i think that's why liberal
democrats will be able to turn these
council victories into parliamentary
victories the next general election okay
i'm going to come at it from a different
angle then and the lib dems and the
greens have done very well in london now
with the greatest will in the world we
can't see the greens having too many
seats come the next general election so
i put it to you again their protest
votes
i'm here to speak for the greens but i
can tell you
sure but the the liberal democrats uh
out many of our victories are in seats
that we can take you're right the greens
can only take a single seat in the next
election liberal democrats can
and in those constituencies which will
decide whether boris johnson
conservatives remain in power next
election it's the liberal democrats that
are challenging and just as we saw in
the cheshire by-election victory and in
north shropshire a lot of people who
might otherwise vote green or labor or
whatever they come behind the liberal
democrats as the party that can remove
the conservative mp or councillor so
that's why i'm a little more optimistic
uh than than you're suggesting kay
there's a real chance here partly
because the conservatives are failing so
badly but partly because the liberal
democrat message
of a tax cut for people who are
struggling of a real investment in care
service not just the health in in care
services as well
a campaign that you may not have heard
of we are really wanting water utilities
to be forced to clean up the sewage they
pump into our rivers it's filthy sewage
the tories are failing to take action so
across the piece the conservatives are
taking voters for granted and liberal
democrats are offering the fair deal
that people want you say that um sure
but um you know given that if we take
that at face value given that it's the
prime minister that has broken the law
given that it's a prime minister that
has floated the rules it would appear on
more than one occasion perhaps on
several occasions given that it's the
prime minister that has been it would
appear misleading parliament
all of that and he is still doing better
than people thought in these local
elections well i don't think he has
actually
and it's not just the prime minister as
i keep coming back it's the conservative
party
i think people were angry that
conservative mps
failed to sack boris johnson you know
you're quite right i mean the only thing
i would disagree with what you said by
the way okay it appeared he lied he
broke the law there's no doubt about
that uh and people do not what was in
his head i put this to the chairman of
the party we didn't know what was in the
prime minister's head and at that time
that's what he believed you know
sometimes i don't know another thing the
prime minister knows what's in his own
head i think he's incompetent i think
he's disgraced i think he's indecent we
have a fantastic country i'm so proud of
our country and to be let down by this
man i think you know
do not underestimate how
how cross the voters are and if
conservative mps don't take don't take
action it didn't convert in the ballot
box so did it i did i mean listen
sorry okay i have to say i am smiling
today because these are historically
good results for the liberal democrats
we've taken a lot of seats off the
tories and if i was a conservative mp
facing a liberal democrat challenge i'd
be really worried i'd be dialing up the
chief whip i'd be dialing up the the
head of the 1922 committee that decides
whether it's going to be voted for no
confidence in the prime minister and i'd
be saying he's got to go i don't know if
we can pull up the state of the party's
graphics stuart but you know um we were
being told to expect four five 800 seat
losses for the conservatives it's not
looking like that at the moment you were
told that by the conservatives to be
honest uh if you looked at this set of
elections independently neutrally uh
before the votes were cast
no party was going to make either
hundred term it's 116 is not a lot no
because these are set of elections where
there was never going to be big losses
or big gains because of the seats that
were being fought and also because the
conservatives had a really bad night
four years ago in my own patch in
kingston for example four years ago we
won 39 out of 48 seats our best ever
results it's quite hard to make more
gains when you've already got 39 out 48
seats the reality is there is a trend
against the conservatives uh and because
they're failing to take action what
voters care about on there for their
families uh well-being whether it's or
their finances or their health the
conservatives are going to be punished
tell me where you stand on what's going
to happen in northern ireland
potentially if shin
well i think we will need to reflect
very very carefully it's a very
sensitive situation sensitive time
and i think all politicians of every
persuasion both in northern ireland
across the uk
should remember that by working across
the communities we've kept peace in
northern ireland that is the most
precious prize and we should work as
hard as ever to make sure that we bring
communities together because it means
real progress in northern ireland real
progress board a referendum if shin fein
wins which is obviously what they're
doing i don't think that is helpful i
think we just need the northern ireland
agreement well i think we should uh
look at the results when they come in
but i also think we should really think
about the future uh i think the problem
i've got with the conservatives is
because of the the protocol in ireland
and the way they've messed around it's
hurting businesses in northern ireland
it's hurting people's incomes in
northern ireland and that's that's
undermining uh uh people's um well-being
and so i really call on the government
to sort itself out to play it's its role
it seems to me that aboriginal
conservatives uh are putting their own
party interest ahead of the interest of
the country yet again okay it's good to
talk to you as always
thank you for coming in when you said
you would it's really appreciated thank
you very much